last factor failing all of these
if if they don't define it for you if
they don't give you
some nice easy required to prove result
that we'll show it to you
and if the language is ambiguous okay
hopefully it's not
then just pick one this big one
um whichever whichever is more
convenient to you
now i don't know how comfortable you
feel with this idea
that you can just really nearly put in a
constant because it's convenient or not
convenient
but actually we've already been doing
this just not in this context okay i
will give you two examples
uh example one
this situation we recognize this don't
we
this is simple harmonic motion yes okay
now
a classic sort of question from here is
okay
get your equation for v squared right
and then go ahead and do something with
that okay
well usually we would probably say if i
want v
squared right we would use half v
squared on this side right
half v squared okay so now what do you
do
you integrate right so that gives you
half v squared equals now what happens
here
divided by 2 increases the power now
what i have to include here since it's
an indefinite integral is a constant
right so you could call it c if you want
however if you want to make things nice
and neat for you you might notice
sometimes the textbook does this
it says let's just call that half c
right you're like wait what do you mean
it's half c
it's it's c isn't it uh but we're
playing the same game that we played
before
versus uh when we were trying to think
about understanding right
c if c is a constant then half c will
also be a constant
right so it doesn't matter it's just
nice and convenient to us now because
when i get my equation for v
squared by multiplying everything by two
minus four x squared plus
c i don't have just another number to
worry about
okay so you see in this case this simple
harmonic
motion case it's just more convenient
for me to define the constant
in a way that's nice and neat does that
make sense
that's kind of obvious it's kind of
plain right let me give you a somewhat
more complicated example that i got
asked about
sometimes textbooks will give this in a
solution at the end
and they give no explanation for this
but this is what they're really doing so
here's example i need more space for
this one
here's example two okay
suppose what you get given is this
you get given an equation for um
velocity sorry the change in velocity
with respect to
displacement no big deal and suppose
where we're going is we want an equation
for
displacement in terms of velocity
right so this is the question right now
just
march through this with me what might we
do at this point this is actually not
that hard it's all in terms of the right
variables right what would i do
you integrate so you get v equals log
x and then you've got a constant flying
around right
okay now at this point what you're
supposed to do is you're supposed to
rearrange this business right you want
to make x the subject
it can be done right but it's actually
neater for me
rather than to say let's call that c
right i might call this
log a okay
if if i know that this thing's going to
be positive um
actually doesn't really matter a it's
just another constant this is where
sometimes textbooks get a bit naughty
and they don't tell you
what a is or where it comes from okay
but can you see if i have some constant
any constant i can just phrase it in
terms of log of some other number
some other constant these are both
constants no problems
why is this useful
i can do log laws on this right and i
don't have to worry about there being
two terms here
the log laws tell me that this is equal
to
log of ax right
so now this is really easy to rewrite i
can put this back into
any digital equation right and then
i get this
okay now of course you can get another
equation for displacement in terms of
velocity
if you went from here but i think this
is much neater it's much easier to work
with and it makes some of the
relationships a little more obvious
okay so what's my point that with regard
to constants
right in the right context you really
can pick whatever you like that makes
the mathematics easier to work with okay
and in fact without without noticing it
we've been doing this all along
because for instance you know it's never
as neat as this
you know resistance is not necessarily
exactly proportional to velocity at a
linear relationship
or to the square of the velocity you
know in real life
it's probably you know proportional to i
don't know some stupid thing like
mkv to the power of 1.8 well i don't
know you have to get a wind tunnel out
and test it out with air resistance and
so on okay that's
an engineer will work that out but my
point is it's not some neat number
we choose a neat number to make the
mathematics easier to work with and it's
still
like it's close enough for us that we
can still get useful information out of
the situation
okay so i i felt a little bit awkward
sort of leaving you
at this point but that's kind of where
the math ends
right hopefully you will never get to
point four right like i said
ninety percent of questions will catch
you here right
another nine percent of questions will
catch you here the
this will be hopefully catching all the
rest and then you know
it's mostly in textbooks where they're
sort of a little more fast and loose and
they're like
you can just look at the answer and
check which one i meant right um where
they where they do this and they and
they let you sort of flounder around and
work out which one you should choose
okay